all right the indianapolis colts went to
cleveland to show what they could do and
they couldn't do it we both were wrong
we both made the cults given one and a
half a best bet what the hell were we
thinking i wish i hadn't listened to you
although i already was going to take the
cults even before i heard you but when
you started talking about the calls it
made me feel even better about it
didn't work out how did the cleveland
browns chris put up 32 points on the
defense that we were calling the best in
the nfl going into last weekend well i i
i think that like a little like we
talked with gruden you know stefanski's
the one that i look at just go wow like
what a what an unbelievable job i mean
you're right this this is one of the
surprises of the weekend to me yeah we
had three best bets this is the one i
felt most confident about and this is
the only one i lost
but
it's i think stefanski deserves a lot of
the credit right off the bat with how he
manages the game you know again playing
through the run and the big thing is
early on
it was a lot of misdirections i mean it
was everything and it was like fake
reverse tight end screens boots reverses
everything like that all the things you
want to do to slow down a really awesome
aggressive front seven so they never let
the colts d-line
ruin the game like they've done just
about in every game they played this
year
the stavansky didn't let that happen and
i really looked at it as like the browns
o with what they did in the first half
and getting
that 20 to 10 lead
uh was really just controlling the clock
doing the right thing that way and then
the defense took over in the second half
which was really cool as well it was
complementary football at its finest and
you know i think the colts did some
things that i would say are a little
stupid but uh you gotta like what what
the browns did and how they looked
overall
yeah and you know i
baker mayfield is just such a different
quarterback when he doesn't have
pressure and and
i i you could say that for most
quarterbacks except patrick mahomes but
you know when when they can just run
that offense yeah mayfield doesn't have
a guy chasing him around you know
because he's caught in between
the mahomes and kirk cousins mobility
specs yeah right in the middle right
right we see him do some great things
when he can get on out on the edge and
run the bootleg and when he doesn't have
a guy tracking him down he can wait and
he can find a guy down the field now he
still did some dumb things in the second
half
you know as he goes the browns are gonna
go and for as bad as he was week one
he's been so much better during this
four-game winning streak and uh that
really stands out to me there's a
confidence there's an extra pop to the
offense when he has time to set up and
work when he doesn't it's all very
different yeah it does well you know
again that's where i give stevansky a
lot of credit hey a guy that i was
critical of when they hired i know
i mean he has impressed me with how he
knows how to manage the big picture of
the football game and he's really kind
of managing baker mayfield right now you
can't trust baker mayfield just to let
it go and let it fly you know he can't i
mean you saw like you just said in the
second half hey both those interceptions
were horrible i mean they were horrible
the first one down the middle with the
lead you have the bobby okariki like i
don't know you're you have a lead your
control of the game it was a bad
decision and a horrible throw and then
the other one you know i know he got hit
as he was throwing the ball but again it
just to me he had no feel that the guy
was coming around the edge and anything
like that so stevansky i think is really
kind of like whoa
baker's got talent he's a little loose i
don't know if i could trust him all the
time we're going to run the ball
reverses reverse passes do all those
type of things and try to make the game
simple for baker until maybe he gets his
feet underneath them in this offense and
everything that way but
stefanski's staying patient with the run
and getting them in third and manageable
mike that was the biggest thing to me
because when the colts get you in an
obvious pass down
and it's third and long you're done
their d line is gonna get to the
quarterback and cause a play and they
really never did that all game long the
other day it was always third and fourth
third and three get the bottom hand
quick they never got to like impose
their physicality on the game like they
have in the other games
well i kept waiting to see deforest
buckner that giant that you acquired in
a trade from the 49ers flashed through
the line and joel petonio was pushing
him back far more often than not so
sometimes you just get neutralized and
you can't do the things that you do
against other teams odell beckham jr he
almost had a taysom hill type of a day
where he had running passing and
throwing
a running receiving and throwing excuse
me he threw a pass for 18 yards
five catches for 58 targeted nine times
he only gave him the ball once he lost a
yard you know stefanski told me last
week
he needs to get the ball in beckham's
hands early i almost feel like
uh there already was the reaction from
the colts
and it opened up other options
offensively right a hundred percent
it was it was it was uh it was uh oh
crap that guy's really good we got to
make sure we're all over him after what
we saw him do to dallas last week and it
did i agreed he was he was the decoy
this week he was i mean he got the
reverse and threw it this week right
because you figure oh he's going to run
we got to get all over that hit's the
big completion to jarvis landry you know
some of jarvis landrisi landry's big
catches down the field he was open
because
you know odell had all three rockets up
his butt on full go steam ahead and they
were running down the field trying to
worry about him so that was big uh you
know just the fact that yeah they
they're still he's very involved in the
game plan the ball just didn't go his
way as much the other way but i think
those are the kind of games like a
receiver can still
feel good because he knows plays were
called for him and the intent was there
to get him the ball but it still helped
out the offense and i think that's the
kind of game like odell they win he'll
be able to live with that all day any
diva receiver i think could live with
that for the most part
i i i don't know how you draw the line
between one rocket two rockets three
rockets what's the most rockets you've
ever achieved i think three three is all
i got you know tyree kill odell there's
a few guys in football that might have
three of the henry ruggs might have
three up there you know then you know
the next level down is two and so on so
we'll see um all right but hey the colts
offense look do you want to hit on that
a little bit
yeah that's what we're doing now we're
going to hear we're going to hear frank
reich talking about philip rivers
because all it takes is one bad game
and uh there are questions about whether
or not philip rivers should still be the
quarterback he's the head coach of the
colts
has there been any consideration to
sitting philip and going to jacoby
no um no consideration for that philip
is our quarterback
and that's that um
you know but just the fact that the
question comes up philip rivers is going
to be aware of that what kind of an
impact does it have on him and look he
didn't look great week one against the
jaguars they lost that game for a reason
they put three good games together he
didn't make any glaring mistakes but
that's the thing with philip rivers
there's just always that possibility
it's always just kind of lingering you
know the pick six that ronnie harrison
and he didn't even have to jump the
route the route jumped him like he was
just kind of hanging around did you see
uh you know it's it's not like he read
it it's just like oh here i am oh
there's the football i'll just grab it
and run the other way with it it wasn't
it wasn't a spectacular athletic play it
wasn't some great anticipation born of
film study it was just
i'm standing here there's the football
i'll take it yeah
you're right well i mean you know
phillip rivers it's a rookie mistake you
know again and it's just unfortunate
that way but you know it's like a golden
rule like you know you always hear like
don't throw across your body don't throw
the ball late in the flat you know he
threw it blind and late in the flat he
was looking down field it was man-to-man
coverage he got pressure and he just
threw it thinking there's my safe throw
he should be open and let's see what
happens and harrison was there it makes
the catch and that that was that but you
know that to me was the bigger part of
the game all and all in all to me that
like where we just talked about
stefanski and gruden and how they
managed the game right and really did it
to help their quarterbacks and do those
things this is one game where
you know frank reich who i think is an
awesome offensive game plan designer i
did not agree with the approach i just
did not too much was put on phillip
rivers from the get-go it's not he's not
that guy anymore philip rivers what we
saw when they've won the three games
prior to that was you know i don't want
to it's kind of game managing like make
a few throws our defense is awesome get
us in the right place we're gonna run
the football and go from there they won
three games in a row this game they came
out with like a pass first approach
which i didn't really understand with
that offensive line and everything they
do there
and i think that's very risky with with
philip rivers and the way he plays right
now out of the fact that the best thing
the brown's got going for them is they
got a front four that's the real deal
they can get after the quarterback when
you throw the ball i'd want to run on
them before i'd want to throw on them
and i think they got kind of caught in
that trap there a little on sunday too
yeah i agree with you and look the call
it's just amazing how one game
causes it to change so dramatically how
we feel about one team or two i feel a
lot differently about the colts yeah and
man do i feel differently about your
life
i'm with you
and chris look i
you know when
i'm so used to
browns and steelers
and always leaning steelers now i
remember a time in 1989 and some browns
fans may remember this and some steelers
fans may try to forget it 51 to nothing
week one the browns beat the steelers
but it's typically always steelers
the steelers are 4-0 for the first time
since 1979
but they have yet to have an
overpowering win they have yet to have a
signature win they have yet to beat a
good team right they've beaten the
eagles the broncos the texans the giants
uh this browns team is gonna give him
everything they can handle it is a hell
of a game coming up on sunday and and i
said last week we're gonna learn a lot
about the browns the next two games
called steelers well we learned a lot
against the colts and i have a feeling
we're gonna learn a lot more against the
steelers and it just it's gonna be but
we got two days to him and haw about our
picks but man
yeah brown's team i i believe
but like you said yesterday believe in
believe land yeah because uh something's
going on there and you look at the
schedule 10 or 11 wins is very very
possible if they get past the steelers
maybe 12 wins yeah no i mean
they're the talent's there it is you
know is there a little inexperience here
and there but like when you look at just
the basic principles of like good
football you go o-line run game pretty
damn good d-line
mike i mean just it's what we talk about
the last three years we're talking about
here's another d-line that can get to
the quarterback without blitzing it's
just a huge huge advantage this day and
age in the nfl so from that standpoint
they got some things there let alone
some of the other playmakers we know
that you go whoa they could be something
uh but i i agree with you last week
really changed my thought of the browns
it really did like it solid you know
just made me go okay
yeah this isn't like fluke and crappy
teams they've played and you know just
caught them right on the right sunday
that was the kind of game i needed like
physical
tough game against a really good defense
it wasn't going to be about flashy big
plays and all those type of things and
they kind of gutted out the win with
some big defensive plays and just some
tough hard-nosed offensive style of
football and i got to give them credit
stafanski joe woods on defense
everything's going good
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports